have you ever considered the true cost
of owning a tesla chances are you are
one of those millions of people who
would have given this question some
amount of serious thought so either you
have already arrived at a conclusion or
maybe you are still undecided on the
subject in today's video we will take a
look at the real charging costs
associated with owning a tesla in the
long run we will explore some concepts
that you might not have considered in
your calculations like wall to wheel
efficiency or phantom drain so stick
around as we do a tesla versus gas head
to head and try to answer whether owning
a tesla is indeed any better than a
regular gas-powered car ev perception
according to a recent auto list survey
one of the top priorities of customers
is still the cost of charging their evs
over a long period there persists this
myth that charging an ev is too
expensive or it takes too long although
we believe that the second part of the
statement is absolutely true evs have
not yet reached a sweet spot for
customers when it comes to charging time
the first part is totally debatable and
definitely worth a closer examination
but first let us go over a few important
considerations to keep in mind while
doing our calculations considerations
for the purposes of simplicity we will
focus on the most popular ev in the
market the tesla model 3 as our base car
for the calculations the math may vary
considerably depending on the different
makes and models second it is important
to keep in mind that where you live will
play a big role in determining the total
charging cost of a tesla your electric
bill will be very different in hawaii
where the cost of electricity is 30.55
cents per kilowatt hour compared to
louisiana where it is only 7.01 cents
per kilowatt hour geography will
influence not only your electric bill
but also battery efficiency since ev
batteries generally tend to work better
in warmer climates than extreme cold
third the charging cycle of your car
will make a difference as well remember
that repeatedly charging the battery
degrades its life over time so you will
have to get into a relatively regular
cycle of charging for your tesla there
may be a bit of a learning curve when it
comes to this since you shouldn't
overcharge your battery or always use
supercharging modes finally we will cap
our charging calculations at an average
of 20 000 miles per year for five years
in total 100 000 miles we feel this is
the best average use case scenario for a
new tesla owner the real charging cost
all that out of the way let us dive into
the costs associated with owning a tesla
model 3. the first cost you want to
consider is the installation of a proper
charging port in your garage if your
daily driving mileage is less than 50
miles then you can probably get away
with using the 110 watt outlet in your
garage but our defined use case has an
average weekly mileage of 380 miles so
most people were required to install a
nema 1450 adapter your tesla model 3
will ship with a mobile connector along
with a nema 1450 adapter the average
cost of such an installation can vary
but most people can get it done within
200 this will enable your tesla model 3
to draw up to 32 amps at 240 volts
charging the batteries at a rate of 30
miles per hour this will take
approximately 10 hours to go from 0 to
100 which is essentially the time you
sleep as a tesla owner you probably want
to get into the habit of charging your
car at home when you are asleep this
kind of charging is probably the most
cost effective and hassle-free way also
nighttime electricity usage usually
comes under off-cycle rates so it will
be a bit cheaper than daytime rates the
us national average cost of electricity
is 10.42 cents per kilowatt hour to be
safe let's round that off to 11 cents
per kilowatt hour while charging it home
now we need to find our model 3's energy
efficiency as per existing user data the
estimated combined highway and city
energy consumption of the tesla model 3
is about 25 kilowatt hours per 100 miles
so your tesla model 3 will use 25 000
kilowatt hours for 100 000 miles but
before we multiply our electricity cost
and the total energy consumption we have
to take a few other factors into
consideration as well efficiency and
drain
the first is your wall to wheel
efficiency since you are reliant on a
power grid to charge your car there will
be losses along the way these will be
because of power plant efficiency
transmission and conversion loss thermal
exchange and so on the wall to wheel
efficiency for a tesla model 3 is around
90 percent according to the tesla 5
charge efficiency user data combining
both home and travel charging it
essentially means that the final amount
of electricity that makes it into the
battery from your 240 volt outlet
through your charger is 10 percent less
the next thing to consider is phantom
drain of the battery when the car is not
plugged in there will be a significant
portion of time when your model 3 would
be parked for long durations of time
during this period there is a tendency
for the battery to slowly drain out its
power this is called phantom drain on
average the tesla model 3 can lose up to
3 charge per day sitting in a parking
lot not plugged in so if we take these
numbers into account the energy
efficiency of our tesla model 3 drops to
around 87 percent hence the total energy
consumption also increases to 29
kilowatt hours per 100 miles or 29 000
kilowatt hours for 100 000 miles
final calculations
if we consider the ratio of home
charging versus travel charging at 80 20
then we can say that 5 800 kilowatt
hours out of 29 000 kilowatt hours came
from the tesla supercharger network or
other gas station charging points
according to tesla the average cost of
these external sources is around 47
cents per kilowatt hour therefore to
recap 200 was our installation cost
eighty percent of charging was done at
home at a rate of eleven cents per
kilowatt hour and twenty percent outside
at forty seven cents per kilowatt hour
doing the necessary calculations we
arrive at a figure of five thousand four
hundred seventy eight dollars thus we
can round it off and say that the cost
of owning and charging a tesla model 3
up to 100 000 miles is around 6 000
to put this figure into context a
comparable gas-powered car like the bmw
series 3 will cost 14 285 dollars to run
100 000 miles at the rate of 28 miles
per gallon of premium gas which averages
four dollars per gallon that is an
insane 8 000 in fuel savings over five
years another thing to add to this tally
of the cost would be the year-to-year
maintenance charges of your tesla model
3. on average evs cost about 900 a year
to repair and maintain whereas
comparable gas powered cars cost about
1200 a year to maintain all this seems
like an easy victory for the model 3 and
the tesla versus gas head-to-head but
wait it gets even better for ev owners
rewards
these days both the government and the
manufacturers are incentivizing ev
ownership in various ways the u.s
federal government offers a 30 tax
credit on chargepoint home flex ev
charging stations plus the installation
costs so if you choose to install
something like that for your tesla you
can get 30 off tesla also offers free
super charging miles as part of their
referral program which can reduce your
travel charging costs even further but
for us the biggest benefit of owning a
tesla long term is definitely the
ability to invest those massive fuel
savings into setting up a home solar
power unit with a rapid
commercialization of home solar panels
and power storage units the economics
are increasingly in favor of ev owners
in fact one doesn't have to even wait
five years or drive 100 000 miles before
they can reap the rewards of a home
solar unit solar power rental programs
in various states across the united
states are getting popular day by day
tesla themselves run out their solar
power systems between 50 and 65 a month
along with a small setup fee so it makes
sense to utilize those savings to reduce
the cost of charging your tesla even
further making the next five years of
ownership even cheaper yes they may not
be the cheapest cars maybe not even the
easiest cars to get used to but the
average cost of charging and owning one
versus a gas powered car just makes more
sense in the long term so there you go
tesla versus gas we think the consensus
is unanimous here the savings makes
tesla the outright winner in this
head-to-head has our conclusion changed
your outlook on buying a tesla as your
next car let us know in the comment
section below hit that like button
subscribe and turn on notifications if
you enjoyed the video thank you and see
you next time